you usually wear faster you got to be
faster if you're ready for it if you
know that this lady's not feeling it
today like I said you got to know your
residence
so if you go in and you're like okay
it's 6 15 in the morning I'm gonna try
her and sometimes man you'll go over
there and hey Miss so and so you ready
to get up and she'll wow and I've got
back your face
go right in the face you can't be
getting too close cause you never know
got me you're you're shaking them out of
a dead sleep and she just woke up swung
and [__] yes she was ready she woke
up and she said not today [__] and I
said yes ma'am and I left
the Honeydew with y'all subscribe today
[Music]